Nếu xúc thật cựh dụng thủ vỳ bị chân 2, kỳ lý tưởng đây là một chân 2 trọng tâm trong cái hậu gì môn của xíu li, lưỡ mấy hài.
Hẹn thả nha rất nhiều, không sinh 2 gà truyền suar sớm, cũng nó hậu bị chân 2 rồi.
Vậy này xây là qua, tức dụng dụng vỳ bị chân 2 có này có này liu lại.
Để có thể biết và hậu đúng tôi nhắn.
Đồng điện thì với chân 2 này nó có thích chân 2 mà là nặng các bệnh đe liên của anh 2 tập nán nhiều hơn lý tüy.
Nhưng các bạn học thì khoảng lấy thấy đúng không?
Nó là chương vình lĩ nhiệt thì làm một chương học mà dòng tính chất liệt,
cho rất nhiều cái sạng ai rất nhiều cái sạng liệt,
cho công tức thì rất là í đỏ.
Nhưng mà trái người lại mới ngoàn xác trưng khi lý tượng
để là một mô mình trong một lý tụi tăng nghiệm kiểu với chất khi,
cho khi mình kiểu chất khi thì nó đẹp,
nó rất nhiều những sạng mai tóan,
đặc biệt là những sạng ai có tức tế.
Lý qua nên các yêu tốt thay đổi, chẳng thái của mình lựa thý tự áng sốt này,
nhìn lộm mà thế tích và đồng họ có mặt,
có một cái tư vý xí lợt tự ki là lâu dịch và có phương phán họt tự kiếm bài bàn,
khi mình có thể học cái cái chương hạn.
Điều xuống hai,
nó là trong lấy thý tình học thì chân này nó một chương học,
chỉ là những dụi tếm số,
chúng mình thì nó sẽ chếm lộ tầm hai lĩnh giữa những bà điểm trong lấy thý,
thì nó sẽ tính chả nó cái chương này nó ngang,
nó sẽ tự chương mấy mạc thì một số bánh mặt lạng bài.
Và trong lấy thý tế tế chương này nó sẽ học cho chúng ta,
chủ yếu vẻ các bạn bài thôi,
đặc biệt là các bạn bây giờ tôi lâu,
lột chắc lưu và phương trình trạc gái tí lý tử ở dạch,
để khi bạn bàn giảng bài và trọng tất cả mạc gần bệ ổn tập,
trong cái chương học này.
Và điều thúa nó các bạn có thậu được chương học này thì có bạn để tham ra lớn vi của thế thành.
Thếp tả, cho lớn viểu thế thành thì đang lên một lộng trình học tập,
bố của mài bàn cho chương học này,
cũng như là tựng bài học sẽ có tự phương phán hại,
cũng thể cho bạn thấy biết cách ám dục của trong tình trường hợp.
Bố chương học, dất là thú vi và rất nhiều thì mài gần khó.
Nhưng mà tần thành sẽ được thành trực tiếp giảng tạng cho lớn vi.
Và hiện tại, điều như là các bạn mạng trước đó,
thì hợp các bạn sẽ nhận tiếp về khoảng sai,
sẽ nó này trở về khoảng lòng hó này của mình sẽ có thể từ vấn trực tiếp cho các bạn.
Gửi cho bạn tham theo xem lộ sĩ hông tập của thế năm nay,
để chúng ta có thể vào lớp,
lần ý để chúng ta học sớp trước thay để nhàng.